[Music]
on this Thursday night The Nightmare
Before Christmas
millions of Travelers across North
America at the mercy of monster storms
we finally gave up on trying to get to
Vancouver the festering frustration at
airports and a look at the forecast
let her learn it's her eyes the backlash
to the Taliban Banning women from
attending University
companion robots the machines improving
lives of Canadian seniors and no dog
left behind I've got to do some work and
come back and get you okay the Canadians
saving canines from the horrors of
Russia's war in Ukraine
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us
extreme weather is the big story of the
day and the next few days frigid
temperatures and Powerful storms are
hitting parts of the U.S already thanks
to a near continent-wide polar vortex
weather warnings or watches are in place
for most of Canada two messy and
dangerous weather is coming that is
certain to disrupt travel yet again
we'll have more on Canada in a moment
but we begin in the U.S where
temperatures are plunging this Fierce
Arctic blast is sweeping across the U.S
Midwest and moving East and the sudden
drop in temperature is dramatic in
Denver today it fell 58 degrees
Fahrenheit in just 24 hours astoundingly
the biggest chunk of that drop came over
a two-hour span last night temperatures
plummeted by 47 degrees Fahrenheit the
flash freeze and the record-breaking
cold is forecast to extend for several
days just as millions of people are
trying to travel for the holidays even
President Biden is warning Americans to
take the storm seriously Jackson prosco
begins our coverage tonight
it's the gift nobody wanted a once in a
generation mix of extreme weather and
very bad timing the Extreme drop in
temperature isn't something we see all
the time heavy snow high winds and
brutal wind chills are sweeping across
the U.S 190 million Americans that's
half the population are under some kind
of weather alert snow is coming and
importantly frigid temperatures and high
winds in parts of Wyoming the wind chill
reached minus 51 degrees Celsius while
Colorado froze so fast the National
Guard was activated serious enough for
U.S President Joe Biden to warn holiday
travelers to leave now while they still
can oh there's dangerous and threatening
this is really a very serious weather
alert arriving just days before
Christmas the storm is wreaking havoc
with Planes Trains and Automobiles some
Travelers tried to get out early
whatever plans we have we want them to
be our plans not the weather's plans
with the airport's plans but thousands
of flights have already been canceled
with few options for rebooking and most
major hubs impacted at the busiest
travel time of the year well I was
originally supposed to fly tonight and
then obviously with the weather as I
thought that's not going to happen it
seems there's no escaping it the freeze
warnings extend all the way to the Gulf
Coast with wind chills bearing down on
Texas where the fragile power grid is at
risk we expect to have sufficient
generation to meet demand throughout
this entire winter weather event Texas
is also where thousands of Central
American migrants have amassed at the
border and on the streets just as
temperatures plunge El Paso has opened a
temporary shelter in its Convention
Center in many places the worst impacts
won't arrive until Friday the busiest
travel day of the year when major East
Coast airports and cities will see heavy
snow when the flash freeze that could
deliver one of the coldest and widest
Christmases in decades
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
well it's likely either you or someone
you know have already had their travel
plans disrupted and brace yourself for
more of that extreme weather is hitting
Canada too every part of this country
except Manitoba and Nunavut is either
under a weather warning the area is in
red or a watch the areas in orange or
those parts in yellow under a special
weather statement plus BC and Ontario
are bracing for another wave of winter
storms on what is the busiest travel
period of the Year turia isri reports
Christmas travel is usually stressful
but for thousands of Canadians this is a
new level of holiday exhaustion
Ottawa booked a trip to Hawaii a much
needed break after her husband's Health
complications but their Connection in BC
was canceled now we're worn out because
of
other problems that we've been having
and we finally gave up on trying to get
to Vancouver this
know when she'll get home to Nunavut how
long have you been at the airport since
4am
for nothing
with a baby on my back a powerful storm
is moving into Ontario and Quebec just
as thousands of passengers are on the
move for the holidays Environment Canada
is forecasting heavy snow freezing rain
and winds as high as 90 kilometers an
hour this one is going to be a big one
and there'll be a lot of impacts for a
lot of people
and people should be avoiding to be on
the road if at all possible while BC
South Coast is preparing for another
round of severe weather things are still
a mess on the roads and at the Vancouver
airport after a storm slammed into the
province earlier this week forcing the
cancellation of hundreds of flights
there's no extra seats on planes
everything is booked up so if you need
to rebook you're going to rebook it a
week later I'm frustrated I got three
kids at home I want to go and spend
Christmas with them the other issue
complicating travel plans is that
passengers say they can't speak to
anyone directly over the phone meaning
they need to keep coming back to the
airport to get answers try to call them
I call them 20 times nobody's talking to
me
long delays and information in short
supply with storms threatening to derail
Christmas plans across the country
a isri Global News Ottawa
well it is winter so cold weather is not
news but the extent of this Arctic blast
what is being described in the U.S is a
bomb Cyclone is exceptional Global News
meteorologist Anthony Farnell puts this
whole thing into perspective for us
Anthony
well Donna when you hear terms like that
meteorologists are referring to the
intensification process of this storm
right now not a lot to it the surface
pressures are pretty high but by
tomorrow it will undergo bomogenesis
it'll become a bomb Cyclone deepening
very quickly bringing in moisture from
the Atlantic our water vapor imagery
shows the depth of this trough all the
way down basically to the Gulf Coast and
then bringing everything back up north
towards the Great Lakes there are
warnings all over the place every
Canadian province most of the U.S as
well wind chill warnings all the way
down to the Gulf of Mexico because of
the Arctic air it's been around for
quite a while on the Prairies more
unusual the further south you go minus
eight still in Vancouver waiting for
another snowstorm potentially tomorrow
mixed with ice at times and then this
storm moves through the Great Lakes
blizzard conditions the winds even into
Atlantic Canada 90 to 100 kilometers per
hour nobody is spared from the extreme
weather over the course of the next
couple of days the good news Donna it
calms down and it warms up as we move
towards the new year
's some good news Global News
meteorologist Anthony Farnell thank you
there are still more questions than
answers about a 2020 National Security
document that alleges the Chinese
government used an extensive network of
community groups to conceal the flow of
funds between Chinese officials and
Canadian members of an election
interference Network Global News has
reviewed that document it warned that
influence operations were likely to be
more persistent and pervasive in future
elections tonight Mackenzie gray looks
into who in the government saw that
document and what if anything was done
about it
well Donna senior cabinet ministers
Melanie Jolie and Dominic LeBlanc have
both said they didn't know about the
privy Council document looking into
Chinese foreign interference but we are
getting some clarity on who does know
about it the only Minister that's
confirmed to Global News they knew about
the briefing emergency preparedness
Minister Bill Blair
um I am periodically given briefings on
on unclassified material I I'm aware of
of that memo and receive certain
information about it Justin Trudeau has
been less forthcoming on what he knows I
get briefed up on it all the time and
our intelligence and security agencies
continue to act responsibly the memo
which sources say outlined a network set
up by an arm of the Chinese Communist
party to try and interfere in the 2019
vote was written by the privy Council
Office the main function of that
department provide documents and give
advice to both the Prime Minister and
cabinet ministers on key issues the pmo
and privy Council are so intertwined
they even share an office former foreign
affairs minister Peter McKay believes
that on issues as sensitive as Chinese
interfere parents the Prime Minister
would have been informed by the PCO I
would I would assume and and would
expect that uh his officials the clerk
of the privy Council his National
Security adviser his cabinet ministers
who have been aware including Minister
Blair if they didn't bring it to his
attention they should be fired Global
News first reported that Trudeau was
briefed on Chinese interference in
January 2022 but with a new PCO document
from February 2020 the conservatives are
now questioning why Trudeau didn't act
sooner on China it's been three years
since then and there is nothing to
indicate that the Prime Minister and his
government have taken this campaign of
interference by Beijing seriously one
thing we could see from the liberal
government to Target foreign
interference a foreign agent registry
we've heard from Public Safety Minister
Marco Mendocino saying the government
will start public consultations on this
issue in the New Year Donna okay
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you the
right to learn coming up protests and
condemnation as the Taliban bans women
from Afghanistan's universities
a day after his surprise visit to
Washington his first overseas trip since
Russia's invasion of his country began
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
is back in Europe
on a stop in Poland zielinski said he
got good results in Washington he met
Poland's president to discuss the trip
in Ukraine's defenses in his speech to
the U.S Congress last night zielinski
appealed to American lawmakers to keep
sending Aid and weapons to his country
the battle is not only for Life freedom
and security of ukrainians or any other
nation which Russia attempts to conquer
this struggle will Define in what world
our children and grandchildren will live
and then they are children and
grandchildren
President Biden committed to send
another 2 billion U.S in aid for
Ukraine's defense including the advanced
Patriot missile air defense system which
zielinski has long requested
the Taliban has dealt another blow to
women in Afghanistan they have been
forbidden from attending University and
other educational institutions and today
some Brave women took to the streets in
anger
[Applause]
this is near Kabul University these
women chanted their opposition to the
ban on education
in jalalabad men joined the rallies in
solidarity with the women there are
reports five women were arrested along
with three journalists covering the
protests the ban on women's education is
being condemned by world leaders but the
outcries are doing nothing to change the
fate of girls and women in Afghanistan
who are slowly having their freedom
eroded crystal gemancing reports
activists are using art and the power of
social media to highlight the isolation
of Afghan women and girls and how their
Futures are being controlled we make
this uh hashtag me and my friend let her
learn to it it means that it's her right
she needs to learn the Taliban announced
Tuesday evening women would no longer be
permitted in universities secondary
schooling was previously halted for
girls
since the Taliban sees power in August
2021 women have risk beatings or Worse
protesting to keep rights they had under
the government of the Islamic Republic
of Afghanistan
National Taekwondo Champion mazia hamidi
fled to France last year women can't
participate in sports work where men are
present travel without male chaperone or
go to school she hopes the social media
Campaign Will Spotlight the realities of
life for women in Afghanistan the way
the hashtag life women Freedom
illuminated the horrors around the death
of 22 year old Masa amini and the
oppression of women in Iran
in Afghanistan women are expressing
their despair so
just say them in words I just want to
yell The Voice you hear is Sonia she was
studying international relations at
Kabul University Global News is not
using her real name or showing her face
for her safety if I had I wanted my own
country my own country without all these
dogs without all these wild animals that
are not letting us
there are videos of men walking out of
University exams and protesting with
women but it appears men in Afghanistan
aren't as public in the fight for
equality as those in Iran for example
advocates in Canada want to see Taliban
leaders sanctioned and opportunities
provided directly to women and girls
support those organizations that plan
online classes online schools online
programs learning programs for app on
women and girls underground schools are
forming Sonia tells Global News she and
her friends are sharing books and
looking for learning materials online as
for public awareness campaigns and
hashtags she says they provide
encouragement
Crystal commencing Global News London
automation Nation ahead how robots are
being used to reduce loneliness
one issue highlighted by the pandemic is
the vulnerability of the elderly they
often live alone or they need care in an
industry suffering from stretched
resources and staff shortages in the
fourth and final story in our series
automation nation and gaviola takes a
closer look at how artificial
intelligence is being put to work in
Elder Care
it's only been a few days but Louise is
already attached to her new device
Alexa I love you I think that's cute
she's part of a pilot project offering
up to 100 seniors a free Echo device
with a screen a companion robot for six
months volunteers will try her out for
free and give feedback eventually I'm
going to be able to every morning have
Alexa tell me Louise you have exercise
at 10 30 today
or there's a bingo this afternoon it's a
partnership with connected Canadians a
non-profit whose mission is to help
seniors get really comfortable with new
technology if older adults don't keep up
they are effectively disconnected from
the rest of the world because not only
are they not able to kind of learn and
gather information but we're also unable
to benefit from the information and
knowledge that they have amassed there
are several Canadian Pioneers in the
field of companion robots too designed
to help those with mobility and memory
issues a tool for tackling feelings of
isolation and loneliness the idea is
deploying these robots there for the
well-being mental well-being but also in
terms of reducing the level of anxiety
and providing this layer of
companionship pilot project devices
don't store personal information but
experts including Ontario's former
privacy commissioner worry about the
lack of consumer protection as
artificial intelligence becomes more
popular and I'm a big Tech fan but you
always always have to know what's going
on you can't just take for granted that
that which you intended is actually
taking place Amazon tells Global News It
generally uses customer data to improve
experiences with its products and
services but doesn't sell customer data
to third parties without consent but
proponents say the benefits of tech
advancements for an elderly population
are enormous
turn a hundred in July
including the centogenarian who makes
voice calls to keep her social calendar
filled do I use it Alexa
at least five times last night
so it was a much easier I didn't have to
look for the numbers and gaviola Global
News Toronto
the former CEO of a cryptocurrency
Empire has been extradited to the U.S
and indicted on multiple fraud and
conspiracy charges FDX founder Sam
bankman freed made a court appearance in
New York he was released on a record 250
million dollars bail he's agreed to stay
at his parents home until the trial the
30-year-old is accused of defrauding
investors by hiding flaws that led to
his firm's bankruptcy and illegally
taking their money for his own use two
of his former Associates have now pled
guilty to similar charges if he's
convicted he faces over 100 years in
prison
saving man's best friend next to
Canadian Charities mission to rescue
dogs from a war-torn Ukraine
[Music]
we often report on the casualties of
Russia's war in Ukraine the terrible
toll on humans who were caught in the
fighting but missing from the stories
are the countless animals Left Behind
the pets that are lost or abandoned well
now a toronto-based charity has been
stepping in to help as many of the dogs
Left Behind as they can and as Mike
troulet explains Ukraine's military
recognizes their work as essential
oh this dog was trying to somewhere in
this war ravaged gas station Jeffrey
Berry was told the dog may be hiding
gingerly he and his team made their way
through the building until they spotted
the scared puppy that's what happens
okay
let's go
there's no getting around it Ukraine is
one of the most dangerous places in the
world to visit yet Barry and his team at
the non-profit no dogs Left Behind first
visited this summer to feed and
sterilize the pet population they
returned in early December at the behest
of the Ukrainian military because of the
problems a Fiero pet population can
bring we don't do that and we're going
to stop vaccinating sterilizing them
then they're going to have rampant
infectious disease spreading and we're
going to have rampant procreation and
then you got the next problems you know
the plan was to tour the blue zones
areas that had been occupied by the
Russians but were now back in Ukrainian
control sterilization campaign how do we
pronounce it
that's not that's not they brought six
tons of dog and cat food and a team to
set up sterilization centers in areas
decimated by War
and as they soon learned under constant
threat of Russian bombardment we got hit
in in Carson missiles landed
10 15 meters from us I mean our cars
went sideways okay and that's when we
had two military
personnel driving they turned us around
and said we gotta lead now in another
location they found a makeshift pound
filled with dogs that had little hope of
surviving it's where Barry found a puppy
he named Yuki I got to assume we're
gonna come back and get you okay and
that they did Yuki a dog of war ended up
on their Charter home to hopefully get
adopted from their Toronto Sanctuary out
of this crazy emotional
days
there's this one amazing moment
microlight Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen I'm going to
take some time off over the holidays I
hope you are able to rest and relax as
well and that any weary Travelers you
know make it to their destination safely
on behalf of everyone at global national
thanks for watching and we wish you
peace and joy tonight's your Canada is
the harbor in Port the grave
Newfoundland and Labrador all lit up for
the holidays we'd love to see your
festive photos of Canada please email
them to viewers globalnational.com I'll
see you again in 2023 for now bye bye
foreign
[Music]